i want to talk a little bit today about
in cells now this is often mentioned
jokingly
but this is really a serious and
important thing it's often mentioned
casually you know a lot of terrorism a
lot of domestic terrorist acts at their
core
are the results of in cells now you
might not know what an incel is in cell
is short for involuntarily celibate in
voluntarily
sell a bit in cell i hope that makes
sense and what it refers to
is an in-cell is someone who
would like to be in a sexual
relationship
but they are unable to get into one
because they either can't find someone
to be in such a relationship with or
they're too you know shy to try or
whatever so they're celibate but not
voluntarily involuntarily now whether
this is
funny or not
it's actually a real source of concern
about the radicalizing effect of in-cell
uh circumstances
and there's a new secret service report
exactly about this and i've mentioned
this in the past many times how many of
these incidents that we are seeing
are a combination of radical political
radicalization
and the frustrations of involuntary
celibacy of course of course of course
never saying
that anybody who can't find a date is
going to go out and commit violence or
act of terror overwhelmingly almost none
of the people that are involuntarily
celibate are going to go out and commit
acts of violence but is it a factor
among some of those that do
a very interesting cbs write-up
new secret service report details
growing in-cell terrorism threat the
federal government on tuesday today
released a study on the growing
terrorism threat from men who call
themselves anti-feminists or
involuntarily
celibates
draw motivation for violence from their
inability to develop relationships with
women tip almost exclusively these are
heterosexual men who would like a
relationship with a woman and are unable
to find one since 2014 attacks inspired
by the incel movement and spanning the
u.s and canada have left dozens dead
early intervention and behavioral threat
assessments could be the difference
between life and death for women
targeted by the growing ideology
according to the 26 page report the
report concluded that while there is no
one profile of an individual who plans
or executes an act of targeted violence
investigators must consider potential
targets when seeking to thwart attacks
as suspects routinely quote explore
multiple targets during the planning
process before making their final
decision the u.s secret services
national threat assessment center took a
deep dive into a serious series of red
flags pre-dating a shooting at a yoga
studio in florida to determine how early
intervention could have saved lives in
the case of 40 year old gunman scott
paul bayerly there were countless
warning signs the man who opened fire
inside hot yoga tallahassee killing two
women and injuring four before
committing suicide had previously been
fired from multiple teaching jobs barred
from bars and apartment buildings and
once authored a 70 000 word revenge
fantasy about a boy turned serial killer
um
there is a um
so put putting that particular um
story aside
uh the whole point here is an analysis
of the idea that there are people
motivated to carry out violence by their
inability to either develop or maintain
a relationship with women now the report
mentions and it's important to consider
the origins of anti-feminist
and in-cell movements vary and they're
not always the exact same thing so there
are people who are radicalized into
extreme anti-feminist ideology
um
not necessarily by their personal
inability to form a relationship with a
woman
but some are
and then along those same lines
not all
in cells are anti-feminists some are
just in cells and they're fine with
feminism but they just can't develop
relationships with women for what may be
a number of different
reasons now jordan peterson has actually
talked about this before jordan peterson
at one point talked about something
called enforced monogamy and he says
that's not literally like you force
people
you you don't forcibly pair women off
with men to prevent them from being in
cells but here's what jordan peterson
had to say about it okay so the question
is
what do you mean by enforced monogamy
well we could start by what i don't mean
i don't mean
taking innocent women at gunpoint and
handing them over to useless men that's
good okay that's a good thing
which is essentially the accusation
you know and it was really interesting
to watch that unfold what i meant was
that
monogamy
as a as something that's socially
uh valued is appears to be essentially a
human universal
that does not actually seem to be true i
mean it that that may well be true in
modern society but historically that's
that's not really been the case doesn't
mean that human beings are
universally monogamous because obviously
we're not we can be serially monogamous
and some people are players and have
multiple partners and all of that but
there's a strong proclivity
across
known societies
to tilt towards monogamy
and the enforcement is social norms
it's like think about it i can't believe
that i even have to say this
your son just gets married and he comes
home and he says guess what dad i've
been screwing around and what do you do
you pat him on the head and you say hey
good work kid that's that's my young man
right well no
you're not happy about that and he
doesn't tell you because he knows you're
not going to be happy about it and
that's enforced monogamy okay so the
idea here is basically the way to fight
this incel stuff is you have to socially
show
that monogamy is acceptable
and lack of monogamy is not but it
really doesn't actually solve the
problem even if if socially
uh
not being monogamous is looked down upon
it's still not going to help a lot of
these cells uh that that that's just
that's just the reality so it's not
clear what we do with this type of
information but it is clear that the
in-cell factor is a real enough factor
that the secret service threat
assessment is to take a term from the
former president looking at it very
strongly let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below